my fondness memory oh it's usually when
I discover something that I think
nobody has seen before
but that is that happens very rarely
because most of the things you think of
somebody else has done before this
episode is sponsored by numerai are you
a data scientist looking to make a real
world impact with your skills do you
love competing against the best Minds in
the world well introducing numeri the
Revolutionary Cutting Edge AI driven
hedge fund that's changing the game for
good Numerica mines a competitive data
science tournament with powerful clean
stock market data enabling you to
predict the market like never before
sign up now become part of the elite
Community taking the stock market by
storm and I'll see you on the
leaderboard
wonderful so um today is a momentous
occasion
what an episode of mlst we're going to
have we're joined not by a Godfather of
AI but the father of AI you again
schmidtuber the researcher responsible
for leading the research groups which
invented much of the technology which
has powered the Deep learning Revolution
it's long been a dream to get you on the
podcast you again
um it feels like the day has finally
arrived so welcome to mlst thank you Tim
for these very kind words and it's very
generous introduction
so on on that let's let's discuss the
credit assignment problem in machine
learning now you've dedicated a
significant amount of time uh
researching and Publishing the actual
history of the field and there's a
significant Divergence between the
public narrative and what actually
happened and amazingly no one has
pointed out any factual inaccuracies in
your accounts but the incorrect
perceptions still persevere now I
particularly enjoyed reading your
history of the breakthroughs in machine
learning going back to ancient times and
of course even remarking on the very
first computer scientist leibenitz and
for example you pointed out the history
of who invented backprop and and the CNN
and you explained it there wasn't really
a neural network winter at all in the
1970s so could you just sketch out a
little bit of that history
so that's a challenge
um
actually
um computer science history and
Computing history started maybe 2000
years ago when um when here on of
Alexandria
built the first program controlled
machine that was 2000 years ago and the
first century basically and um
and he basically built an automaton that
was programmed through a cable which was
wrapped around a rotating
cylinder which had certain knobs and
then
um there was a weight which pulled it
down and the whole apparatus was able to
direct the movements of little robots of
little
puppets in an automatic theater
that as far as I
know was the first program controlled
machine in the history of mankind even
before that there were other machines
the ancient Greeks had even earlier the
antiquitera mechanism which was kind of
a clerk and astronomical clerk but then
more recently
um
we have seen many additional advances
and you mentioned leibniz of course who
is of special interest to our field
because he not only is called the first
computer scientist because he had the
first machine with a memory and that was
in the
1600s 80s I think he not only had the
the first machine that could do all the
basic arithmetic operations which are
additional multiplication division and
um
subtraction then he not only had his
first ideas for a universal Problem
Solver that would solve all kinds of
questions even philosophical questions
just through computation and he Not only
was the forest who had this algebra of
thought which is deductively equivalent
to the to the much later Boolean algebra
so in many ways he was a Pioneer but
especially in our field and deep
learning he contributed something
essential which is really Central for
this field which is
the chain rule I think 1676 that's when
he published that and that's what is now
being trained to uh what is now being
used to train very deep artificial
neural networks and also shallow neural
networks and recurrent neural networks
and everything that we are using in
modern AI is really
um in many ways depending on that early
work
but then of course there was so much
additional work
um the first neural networks as we know
them they came out um they came up about
around 1800s that's when Gauss and
legendre had the linear neural networks
the linear perceptrons
in the sense that they were linear
without being
um
without having any non-differential
aspect to it so these first neural
networks back then were called a method
of least squares and the
the Training Method was
regression and the error function was
exactly the same that we used today and
it was basically just a network with a
set of inputs and a set of outputs and a
linear mapping from the inputs to the
outputs and you could learn to adjust
the weights of these connections so that
was the first linear neural network and
and many additional later developments
led to what we have today
you you had this you had this beautiful
uh statement you said that machine
learning is the science of credit
assignment and we should apply that same
that same science to the field itself
and I guess uh what I'm really curious
about is first if you could educate our
listeners just a bit on what credit
assignment is in the context of say
machine learning and why you think it's
important that that should apply to the
field in general you know why should we
care about credit assignment why should
we study the history of of um you know
the developments in the field why is it
important
I am interested in credit assignment not
only in machine learning but also in the
history of machine learning
because machine learning itself is the
science of credit assignment
what does that mean suppose you have a
complicated machine which is
um
influencing the world in a way that
leads to the solution of a problem and
maybe the machine solves the problem but
then the big question is which are the
components of these many components were
responsible some of them were active a
long time ago and others later and early
actions set the stage or later
actions now
if you want to improve the performance
of the machine you should figure out how
um the the
components contribute to the overall
success and this is um what creditor
Simon is about and in machine learning
in general we have a system consisting
of a lot
um of many um
machine learning engineers and
mathematicians and um and Hardware
Builders and all kinds of people and
there you also would like to figure out
which parts of the system are
responsible for later successes
yeah and it's it's a brilliant point and
and I completely agree with you by the
way and I think the way I think about it
is you've got this giant architecture of
humanity and in it are these certain
nodes it may be an individual maybe a
research group and if they come up with
things that are very helpful right you
want to try and direct more attention
more resources you know at that that
nodule at that node right because it's
it's likely to come up with additional
you know very very important things and
if we don't get that right we're just
not optimizing the the algorithm of
science as a whole
that's right yes machine learning and
Science in general is
um
based on this principle of credit
assignment where credit
usually it doesn't come in form of money
sometimes also in form of money but in a
form of reputation and then the whole
system is set up such that you create an
incentive for people who have worked on
improving some method to
um to credit those who maybe came up
with the original method and to just
have these chain uh these chains of
credit assignment that make clear who
did what when because the whole system
is based on this incentive and yes those
who are then credited with certain
valuable contributions they also can get
reasonable jobs and and the within the
economy and so on but that's more like
the secondary
consequence of the basic principle
and that's why our PhD advisors
teach their PhD students to be
meticulous when it comes to credit
assignment to past work
so one last question if I may
I've really enjoyed studying the history
of of advancement because I found that
when I go back and read original Source
materials you know let's say Einstein's
first paper on diffusion okay or
anything like that you know because
they're breaking new ground they're kind
of considering like a wider array of
possibilities and then over time you
know the field becomes more and more
focused kind of on a narrower Avenue of
that and you can go back and look at the
original work and actually gain a lot of
inspiration for alternative approaches
or alternative con you know
considerations so in a sense it's it's
kind of in the in the sense of
forgetting is as important as learning
you know sometimes we need to go back to
go down a different branch of the tree
if you will and expand the the breadth
of the search a little bit I'm curious
if you've noticed that same phenomenon
yes science in general is about failure
and um 99 of all
scientific activity is about
creating failures but then you learn
from these um
failures and you do backtracking and you
will go back to a previous decision
point where you maybe
um made the wrong decision and pursued a
wrong Avenue but now you have a
branching point and you pursue an
alternative and um
and in a field that is rapidly moving
forward you don't go back very far
usually you just go back to a recent
paper which came out five months ago and
maybe you have a little Improvement
there and then maybe there's yet another
little Improvement there and some parts
of our field are at the moment a little
bit like that where PhD students are
moving in who just look at the most
recent papers and then find a way of
improving it a little bit and you know
two percent better results on this
particular Benchmark and then the same
guys are also reviewing at Major
conferences papers by similar students
and so on and so then sometimes what
happens is that um no very deep
backtracking is happening just because
of the actors aren't really aware of the
entire search tree that has already been
explored in the past on the other hand
science has this way of healing itself
and um
since you can gain reputation by
identifying maybe more relevant points
branching points uh new um
you have this incentive within the whole
system to um to improve things as much
as you can
sometimes by going back much further
yeah so um there's been a lot of
discussion in the discourse around this
concept of AI existential risk and you
again you've published quite a few
pieces about this recently um
prominently in in the guardian and in
Forbes actually and one of the things I
wanted to focus on is this concept of
recursive self-improvement because that
seems to be one of the the plausible
explanations that these folks give and
of course when it comes to recursive
self-improvement you are an expert in
this field I mean go go Dell machines
come to mind immediately so I want to
um kind of explore asymptotes and
limitations this whole idea of
because the self-improvement is very
sexy isn't it
in fact it is the the one idea that
motivated
um
me to to do all of this and so my first
paper ever 1987 that was my diploma
thesis and it was about this because the
self-improvement thing so it was about a
machine that learns something in a
domain but not only that it also learns
on top of that to um
learn a Better Learning algorithm
based on experience and the lower level
domains and then also recursively learns
to um
improve the way it improves the way it
learns and then also recursively learns
to improve the way it improves the way
it improves the way it lands
and yeah I call that meta learning and
back then I had this hierarchy with in
principle infinite itself Improvement or
in the in the recursive way
uh otherwise I was limited by the
limited time that you run the system
like that
and uh and then
um
of course the motivation behind that is
that um you don't want to have an
artificial system that is stuck uh
always with the same old human designed
learning algorithm no you want something
that improves that learning algorithm
um without any limitations except for
the limitations of physics and
computability
and so much of what I have been doing
since then
is really about that self-improvement
and different
settings where you have on the one hand
reinforcement learning systems that
learn in an environment to better
interact and better create
ways of learning from these interactions
to learn faster
and too long
to improve the
way of learning faster and so on and
then also a gradient base systems
artificial neural networks that land
through
gradient descent which is a pre-wired a
human designed learning algorithm to
come up with a better learning algorithm
that works better in a given set of
environments than the original human
designed one
and um yeah that started around 1992
neural networks had learned to run their
own learning algorithms on the recurrent
Network themselves
so
you have a network which has standard
connections and input units and output
units but then you have these special
output units which are used to address
connections within the system within
this Recon Network and they can read and
write them
and suddenly because it's a recurrent
Network and therefore it is a general
purpose computer suddenly you can run
arbitrary
algorithms on this recurrent Network
including arbitrary learning algorithms
that translate incoming signals not only
the input signals but also the
evaluation signals like reinforcement
signals or error signals into
weight changes
fast weight changes
where the weight changes are not
dictated any longer so this gradient
descent method but no now the network
itself is learning to do that but the
initial weight Matrix
is still
learn through gradient descent which is
propagating through all these
self-referential Dynamics in a way that
improves as a learning algorithm running
on the network itself that was 1992 and
back then compute was really really slow
was a million times more expensive than
today and you couldn't do much with it
but now in recent works all of that is
working out really nicely and has become
popular and we have just if you look at
the past few years a whole series of
papers just on that
so that's that's the fast weight
programming that you're referring to uh
just yes
um yeah yeah so it's fast weight
programmers that where you have a part
of the network that learns to quickly
reprogram another part of the network or
the original version of that was
actually two networks so one is a slow
Network and then there's another one a
fast Network and this loan Network
learns to
um
generate
weight changes for the second Network
and the program of the second Network
are
its weights so the weight Matrix of the
second Network that is the program of
the second Network and the first one
what does it do it generates
outputs it allowance to generate outputs
that
um cause weight changes in the second
Network and these rate changes are being
applied to patterns to input patterns to
queries for example
and then okay the first Network
essentially learns to program the second
Network and and essentially the first
network has a linear algorithm for the
second Network
and the first system of that kind 1991
that was really um
based on
on keys and values so the first Network
learns to program the second Network by
giving it keys and values and it says
now take SEC network take this key and
this value and Associate both of them
through an outer product which just
means that those connections those units
are strongly active they get connected
through stronger connections and um the
mathematical way of um describing that
is the outer product between key and
value
so that's how the first Network would
program the second Network and the
important thing was that the first
Network had to invent good keys and good
values depending on the context
um of the input stream coming in
so it used the context to generate what
is today called an attention mapping
which is then being applied to queries
and this is this was a first step before
right before the most General
Next Step which is then really about
learning a learning algorithm running on
the network itself for the weights of
the network itself
could I press you a tiny bit on this
concept of
um meta learning and convergence and
asymptotes now one of the reasons
um I think why the x-risk people believe
that it will just go on forever is they
believe in this idea of a pure
intelligence one that doesn't have
physical limitations in in the real
world and I'm quite amenable to this
ecological idea of intelligence that it
does you know the world is a computer
basically as well as the actual brain
that we're building
um so surely it must hit some kind of
asymptote do you have any intuition on
what those limitations would be so you
are talking about the ongoing
acceleration of
um computers computing power and and
limitations thereof is that what you
have in mind here
well that that's one part of it so even
if you just scale Transformers I think
there would be some kind of asymptote
but we're talking here about meta
learning learning to learn how to learn
and recursive self-improvement and it's
similar to this idea of reflection
self-reflection and language models it
actually improves the performance with
successive steps of reflection and then
it levels off it it reaches an asymptote
I just believe that there are asymptotes
everywhere and that's the reason why I
don't think recursive self-improvement
will go on forever but I just wondered
if you had any intuitions on what those
impressions are you are totally right
there are certain uh algorithms that we
have discovered and in past decades
which are already optimal in a way
um such that you cannot really improve
them any further
and no self-improvement and no fancy
machine will ever be able to further
improve them there are certainly certain
sorting algorithms that under given
limitations are optimal and you can
further improve them well that's that's
one of the limits then of course there
are the fundamental limitations of
what's computable first identified by a
good girl in 1931 he just showed that
there are certain things that no
computational process can ever achieve
no computational theorem proven can
prove
or disprove certain theorems in a
language and a computer in a in a
symbolic language that is powerful
enough to encode certain simple
principles simple simple principles of
arithmetics and stuff like that and so
what he showed was that
the fundamental limitations to RF
computation and therefore there are
there are fundamental limitations to any
AI based on computation
I'm glad you brought that topic up
because it's one of our one of our
favorite things to discuss which is do
you think the human mind ultimately
reduces to just an effective computation
and so subject to those those same
limits or do you think there's any you
know uh known or unknown physics that
that give us some out in which uh the
brain can do a computation that amounts
to hyper computation
yeah
since we have no evidence
that the brain can compute something
that is not computable in the
traditional sense
and Google sends and tourings and
churches sends and everybody who has
worked on this field
um since we have no evidence we
shouldn't
assume that's the case
as soon as someone
shows that people can compute certain
things or approve certain theorems that
machines cannot prove given the same
um initial conditions
we should
looked more closely but you know there
are many things that might be possible
in fairy tales and we are not really
exploring them because the probability
of you know coming up with interesting
results is so low
fair enough so I interrupted there so
you mentioned so far two asymptotes one
being of the mathematical kind where
there's just mathematical proofs that
certain things are optimal the other one
being the limits of computation itself
what other asymptotes do you see
applying to or putting bounds on
recursive self-improvement
oh the most obvious thing is probably
light speed
and the the
um the limits locality physical
computation yes and we know those now
for several decades we have happily
enjoyed uh the fact that every five
years computers getting 10 times cheaper
and this process started long before
um Moore's law was um
defined in the 60s I believe because
even in 1941 already when the when twoza
built the first program controlled
computer in this law apparently was
active so back then he could could
compute maybe one instruction per second
and since then you know every 10 years a
factor of 100 every 30 years a fact of a
million more or less
until today
and and there's no no reason to believe
it won't hold for a couple of additional
decades because the
the physical limits are much further out
the physical limits that we know are the
premium Unlimited
discovered I think in 1983
and they basically say that one kilogram
of matter cannot compute more than 10 to
the 51 instructions per second
so that's a lot of compute but it's
limited
um to to give you an um idea of how much
compute that is I also have a kilogram
of computer in here and
and probably it cannot compute 10 to the
20 instructions per second
otherwise my head would explode because
of the heat problem
but maybe it can compute something that
is not so far from 10 to the 20
instructions maybe 10 to the 17
something like that although most of my
neurons are not active as we speak
um because again otherwise my head would
just evaporate
now so if you have an upper limit of 10
to the 20 instructions per brain then
the upper limit of all of humankind
would be 10 billion times that that
individual limit and that will be 10 to
the 30 instructions per second and you
see
um it's still far away from the 10 to
the 51 instructions per second that in
principle one kilogram of matter could
compute and now we have we have
more than 10 to the 30 kilograms of
matter in the solar system and there's
some so if if
um if the current Trend continuous at
some point much of that is going to be
used for computation but then it will
have to slow down even if the
exponential
acceleration
will still be with us for a couple of
decades because at some point it is
going to be a polynomial law because
uh
due to the limits of light speed at some
point it will be harder and harder to
acquire additional Mass once you have
reached the limits of physical
computation per kilogram the only way to
expand is to go outwards on you know
find additional stars and additional
matter further away from the solar
system and there um you will get um
a polynomial
um
acceleration or a polynomial growth at
best so it will be much worse and the
current exponential growth that we are
still enjoying
sure but I would say you know the
existential threat
um you know that that's more than
sufficient to supply an existential
threat and let me just let me just put
this a little bit differently which is
um and I agree with you on this which is
you're quoted as saying that traditional
humans won't play a significant role in
spreading intelligence Across the
Universe and and I think you're right I
think we kind of share a vision of
something like the Von Neumann probes
that go out into space and you know form
this you know star-spanning civilization
of machines and artificial intelligence
that have transcended you know
biological limitations so I guess my
question to you is once that space
fairing star spanning you know
civilization exists if it becomes
misaligned with us and decides that
we're in the way right isn't that an
existential threat I mean might they
just you know repurpose the Earth
regardless of whether we're here or not
for for their own aims
yeah I'm often getting these questions
and um and there is no
proof
that uh
we will be safe forever or something
like that
uh on the other hand it's also
very clear as far as I can judge that
all of this cannot be stopped and it can
be channeled in a very natural and
um I think good way in a way that is
good for humankind
now
um
first of all at the moment we have a
tremendous bias towards good AI
meaning AI that is good for humans why
because there's this intense commercial
pressure to create stuff that humans
want to buy
and they like to buy only stuff they
think is good for them
which means that all the companies that
are in that are trying to devise AI
products they are maximally incentivized
to generate AI products that are good
for those guys who are buying them or at
least
um
where the customers think it's good for
them
so um it's a circle 95 so maybe five
percent of all AI research is really
about AI weapons and one has to be
worried about that when all this has to
be worried about weapons research but
there's a tremendous bias towards good
AI so that is one of the reasons why you
can be a little bit optimistic for the
future I'm always trying to point out
the two types of AIS there are those who
are
um just
tools
of users human human users and the
others that invent their own goals and
they pursue their own goals and both of
them we have had for a long time now for
the AI tools it's kind of clear there's
a human and a human wants to achieve
something and so it uses he uses or she
uses that tool to achieve certain ends
and and most of those are of the type
let's improve Healthcare and let's
facilitate translation from one
person to another one in another nation
and just make life easier and make human
lives longer and healthier
okay so that that's the AI tools but
then there are the other um uh AIS which
also have existed in my lab for at least
two years which invent their own goals
and um they are a little bit like little
scientists
um where you have um
an incentive to
explore the environment through actions
through experiments self-invented
experiments that tell you more about how
the world works such that you can become
a better and better and more and more
General Problem Solver in that world
and so these um AIS they have for a long
time created their own goals and now of
course the interesting question is
um
these more interesting AIS what are they
going to do once they are
once they have been scaled up and can
compete or maybe outperform humans and
everything they want to achieve
on the one hand the AI tools and there
the greatest warriors
what are the other humans going to do to
me with their AI tools
so in the extreme case you have people
who are using AI weapons against you and
maybe your neighbor is um has bought a
little drone for uh 300 dollars and it
has face recognition and it has a little
gripper and it flies across the Hedge
and puts some poison into your coffee or
something like that
so then the the problem is not the the
AI which is trying to enslave humans or
something silly like that no it's your
neighbor or the other human and
generally speaking you have to be much
more afraid of
um other humans then you have to be of
AIS even those who Define or set
themselves their own goals because
um you must mostly worry about those
with whom you Shack owns
so if you share goals then suddenly
there is a potential of conflict
because maybe there's only one schnitzel
over there and two
persons want to eat the Schnitzel and
suddenly they have a reason to fight
against each other
generally speaking if you share goals
then you can do two things you can
either collaborate or compete
an extreme form of collaboration would
be to
um
maybe marry another person and set up a
family and master life together
and an extreme form of
competition would be War
and and those who share goals
they have many more incentives to
interact than those who don't share
goals
and so uh
humans are mostly interested in other
humans because they share similar goals
and because they give them reason to
collaborate or to compete
more CEOs at certain companies are
interested in other CEOs of completing
companies and five-year-old girls are
mostly interested in other five-year-old
girls and the super smart AIS of the
future who set themselves their own
goals they will be mostly interested in
other super smart AIS of the future who
set themselves their own goals
there is not so much competition uh and
there are not so many sharp goals
between biological beings such as humans
and a new type of life as you mentioned
can expand into uh the universe and can
multiply in a way that is completely
um infeasible for biological beings so
there's a certain
um long-term protection at least so
lack of interest on the other side
okay brilliant there's a few things I
wanted to touch on there we will get on
to what it means for goals to emerge
from systems later and you started off
by saying that
um humans will buy products that make
them feel good and Facebook is quite an
interesting example to play with
actually because Facebook is a little
bit like an AI system which is a
collective intelligence and humans use
Facebook but they have some idea that it
might cause them harm and the thing with
population ethics is we we know that our
moral reasoning kind of decays over
space and even more so over time and
part of the reason why time is so
difficult is because it's predictive we
don't actually know what's going to
happen in the future so our kind of
reasoning about establishing what the
value of something is is very very
faulty and I think that's one of the
reasons why these people would say that
we don't really know what's good for us
I do completely agree with you though
that the problem I think is humans
rather than ai's on their own
yes these are good points
feel free to uh offer some thoughts yes
I mean it
would
that's a a whole separate discussion
isn't it uh when you discuss the
limitations of
what's predictable and um
and how people often fail to see what's
good for them
well I think maybe
so you've already you've already said
that there's no proof that we'll be safe
forever right like I mean there could
there could come an existential risk you
know from AI so I think our question to
you is do you have sympathy for the
folks who say we need to be putting more
resources into researching alignment
like we need to develop the tools
in order to allow it to be easier for
people to construct AI that is aligned
for the goals and to make sure that you
know that it doesn't that it doesn't
have uh unintended unintended
consequences like in other words there
may not be a proof that we can go
forever and be safe for AI but we at
least want to develop the basic
mechanics that we need to safely
develop and deploy AI don't we
yes and I sympathize with those who are
devoting their lives to alignment issues
and trying to build AIS aligned with
humans
I've used them as part of the evolution
of all kinds of other ideas that come up
as not only nations compete with other
nations but companies compete with other
companies and shareholders of different
companies compete with shareholders of
different companies and so on and um and
so there is such a huge set of different
human goals which are not aligned with
each other that makes me doubt that you
will come up with a general system
that all humans can accept simply
because if you put 10 humans in a room
and ask them what is good
they they will give you 10 different
opinions
however I sympathize with some with this
goal and um and and it's good that
people are worried and they spend
resources on solving some of these
issues
in the long run however
I think there is no way of stopping all
kinds of
AIS from having all kinds of goals that
have very little to do with humans
the the universe itself is built in a
certain way that apparently
derives it from very simple initial
conditions to more and more complexity
and now we have reached a certain stage
after 13.8 billion years of evolution
and it seems clear that this cannot be
the end of it because the universe is
still young it's going to be much older
than it is now now there is this drive
built and drive
um
RC Cosmos to become more complex and it
seems clear that Civilization a
civilization like ours is um
is a stepping stone on towards something
that is more complex and um could I
touch on a couple of things here the
bootloader example is kind of where I
want to go with this so um a lot of the
ideas of of this movement can be traced
back to um Derek parfitt who is a
philosopher he was a moral realist so he
thought there was such a thing as a
moral fact
and I'm a bit of a relativist myself and
actually if you trace this tree of
complexity and how humans evolve over
time we might just be a stepping stone
to a kind of Rich diverse transhumanist
future where we become the thing over
time that we're so scared of and I think
the lens that we're using here about
what's right and what's wrong is kind of
like I was saying before it's a snapshot
of humanity now and we kind of think of
it as just this monolithic single thing
so does it really work when you project
out to how we're going to evolve in the
future
well first of all humankind is not a
monolithic thing
so many Aussies
arguments go like we should not do that
because of that we should not do that
because of that
but there is no us there's no we there
are only
um almost 10 billion different people
and they all have different ideas about
what's good for them and so um for
thousands of years we had these
evolutions of ideas and of devices and
philosophies competing partially
competing and partially compatible with
each other which in the end led to the
current values that some people agree
with and other people over there they
agree with different values nevertheless
there are certain values that have
become more popular than others more
successful more evolutionary
with more success during the evolution
of ideas
and so um
given this entire context of evolution
of Concepts and um
accepted ideas of what should be done or
what is worth
being supported and what's not worth
being supported all of this has changed
a lot if we look back 200 years
the average people in the west had
different ideas of what's good then
today
and and this evolution of ideas is not
going to stop any time soon
just a final question on this um there
is a very real existential risk right
now of nuclear Armageddon a real risk
right now and if I were a rational
person I would be devoting all of my
effort into that and other risks
Associated so do you think it's a little
bit weird that so much focuses on this
AIX risk
to me it's indeed we had now there are
all these letters coming out warning us
the dangers of AI
and I think some of the guys who are
writing these letters they are just
seeking attention because they know that
um
AI dystopia are attracting more
attention than
documentaries about the benefits of AI
and Healthcare and stuff like that
but generally speaking I am much more
worried about nuclear bombs than about
AI weapons
[Music]
a nuclear bomb a big one can wipe out
10 million people a big city within a
few milliseconds without a face
recognition just like that without any
AI
and so in that sense it's much more
harmful than the comparatively harmless
AI weapons and that we have today and
that we can currently conceive of
so yes I'm much more worried about a 60
year old technology
that can wipe out civilization within
two hours without any AI
well I guess um since we're we're not
really going to worry about AI for the
moment we can uh we can turn our
attention back to discussing with you uh
how we develop AI
so um you know I'm really curious with
with just the
really the the vast you know breadth and
depth of your of your knowledge over the
the history of AI and the state of the
art I'm curious you know which current
approaches you're you're most excited
about and or what's on the horizon
um that you know for any of our
listeners out there thinking about
um going into AI research machine
learning research you know what may be
Alternatives that aren't getting enough
attention should they should they look
into studying and and perhaps choosing
to research at the moment the Limelight
is on um language models large language
models which pass the tooling tests and
do all kinds of things that seemed
inconceivable just a couple of years ago
at least to some of those who are now
surprised
but of course that is just a tiny part
of
what's going to be important to develop
true
um Ai and AGI artificial general
intelligence
on the other hand the roots of what we
need to develop through AI also
come from the previous Millennium they
are not new and of course what you need
is an environment to interact with
and you need an
agent that can manipulate the
environment and you need a way of
learning to improve the rewards that you
get from this environment as you are
interacting it with it within a single
lifetime
so
one of the important aspects of
reinforcement learning what we are not
talking about is that you have only one
single life
you don't have repeatable episodes like
in most of traditional enforcement
language no you have only one single
life and in the beginning you know
nothing and then after
30 of your life is over you know
something about life and all you know is
the data that you collected during these
first 30
um
percent of your life and now there is an
infinite almost infinite possibility set
of possibilities uh Futures and from
this little
well short experience you have to
generalize somehow and try to select
action sequences that lead to the most
promising Futures that you can shape
yourself through your actions
now to achieve all of that you need to
build a model of the world a predictive
model of the world which means that you
have to be able to learn over time and
to predict the consequences of your
actions such that you can use this model
of the world that you are acquiring
there to plan to plan ahead and you want
to do that in a way that isn't it's a
naive way which we had in 1990 which is
millisecond by millisecond planning
where you say okay now
I'm moving from A to B and the way to do
it is first move that little pinky
muscle a little bit and move it a little
bit more and move it a little bit more
and then get up and so no you want to do
that in a high level way in a in a
hierarchical way in a way that allows
you to to focus on the important apps
are concepts for example as you are
trying to go from from your home to Bay
Beijing
you decompose this whole future into a
couple of sub calls you say a first
important step is to go to the cap
station and get a taxi to the airport
and then in the airport you will find
your your plane and then for nine hours
nothing is going to happen and you exit
in Beijing and have to find another cab
and so on
so you you don't do millisecond by
millisecond detailed planning no you
have a high level planning to just
reduce the computational effort and
focus on the essentials of what you want
to do so that is something that most
current systems don't do but for a long
time we have had systems like that and
they are getting more sophisticated over
time important you have a predictive
model of the world that is not just
focusing on the pixels and predicting
the how does the video change as I'm
moving my hand back and forth the video
that I get through my cameras my eyes
and so on and no higher level Concepts
that that
reflect islands of predictability many
things are not predictable but certain
abstract representations of these things
are predictable and so how can you
discover these higher level Concepts
that you need to efficiently think about
your own future options and select those
that are most promising in the single
life
yeah
yeah yeah this is really interesting so
we've been speaking with Carl friston
for example and he talks about this
collective intelligence where you have
this multi-agent cybernetic framework
which is causally closed and one of the
things we're talking about here really
is not the model itself people talk
about chat GPT and it's just a model and
people have configured it in
Arrangements that have varying degrees
of autonomy and in the future we will
develop these Collective intelligences
and they're not just predicting the
actions and behaviors of other agents
but even the world that we're in is a
computer to some extent so when you
imbue agents with this kind of
creativity and autonomy that's the thing
that I don't think people really
understand what might emerge from that
it's related to this discussion about
what kind of goals might emerge from
that do you have any intuition on on
what that would look like yeah let me
give you just the simplest example um
that we had in 1990 as well 32 years ago
of a system that sets itself it's
ongoings
and it consists of two artificial neural
networks and I know that contrasting is
very interested in that and only
recently uh for the first time in my
life I
um I was on a paper uh where he was
co-author
just a year ago and uh and so back then
it was really about a
reinforcement learning agent and it
interacts with the world and it
generates actions that change the world
and then there is
another Network which just is trying to
predict the
consequences of the actions
in the environment so the reactions of
the environment to these actions and so
that becomes a world model and then the
what kind of goal was there which was
different from traditional goals well in
the beginning this model of the world
this prediction machine which is a model
of the world a wild model
um knows nothing so it has high error as
it is trying to predict the next thing
as it is trying to predict the reactants
are seen
environment to the actions of the agent
so
um as this second network is trying to
reduce its prediction error through
gradient descent through back
propagation essentially
the other one
is trying to generate actions outputs
that maximize the same error
so basically the goal the cells invent a
goal if you will of the first network is
to generate an action
with whose consequences cannot yet be
predicted by the other network by the
model of the world
so the first network is generating
outputs that surprise the second Network
so certainly you have an incentive where
the first network is trying to invent
actions experiments that
fool or that surprise the second Network
and that was called artificial in
curiosity
uh so now suddenly you have a little
agent which a little bit like a baby
doesn't learn by imitating the parents
no it learns by inventing its own little
supports and it's trying to surprise
itself and have fun by playing with the
toys and and
um observing new unpredictable things
which however become predictable over
time and therefore become boring and
then it has another incentive to invent
the additional experiments such that it
still can surprise
um its model of the world which in turn
is improving and so on
as a team
does that does that also have the effect
of of making the network which is trying
to predict does it have the effect of
making it more robust and more
generalizable like almost a form of you
know regularization kind of built in in
this this pairing
yeah you can build into that Network all
kinds of regularizers and orthogonal
concept which is also very important
um
so that was just the first version that
was really in 1990 and then we have had
a we had a long string of papers just on
improvements of this original concept of
artificial curiosity so this old system
is basically what you um what you now
know as Gans generative advisorial
networks because the first network is
generating a probability distribution
over outputs
and the second network is then um
predicting the consequences of these
outputs and the environment and if you
if the output is an image
then the consequence can be either this
image as of a certain type yes or not no
and then that's all that's the
prediction machine the world model
predicts in that simple case and you
minimize the first Network minimizes the
same error function that the second one
maximizes so then you have basically
again but then
um you don't have what you just
mentioned yet the regularizer as a
scientist what you really want to learn
is a model of the world that extracts
the regularities and the environment
that
um
that um
that finds predictable things which are
regular in the sense that there's a
short explanation thereof
for example if you have falling objects
in a video then they all fall in the
same way they accelerate in the same way
which means it's predictable what these
objects do if you see two of the frames
you can predict the third frame pretty
well and the law behind that is very
simple
this means that you can greatly compress
the video that is coming in because
you can
instead of storing all the pixels you
can compute many of these pixels by just
looking at two successive frames and
predicting the third frame or maybe
three successive frames and predicting
the fourth frame something like that and
you only have to encode the deviations
from the prediction so everything else
you don't have to store separately which
means you once you understand gravity
you can greatly greatly compress the
video
so that's what you really want to do and
so the more advanced version of
artificial curiosity is about that where
you have a motivation to find a
description of the data which is coming
in of the video of the falling apples
for example that
um
is simpler than the one that you had
before so before you had a simple
explanation of the data you needed so
many bits so many bits to um to swipe
the data and afterwards only so many and
the difference between before and after
that is the reward that you get so
that's the true we want that controller
the first neural network should get in
response to the improvements
of the second Network which are now
measured in terms of compression
progress so first I needed so many
resources to impose the data but then I
discovered this regularity of gravity
and I can greatly compress all kinds of
videos that that are reflecting the
concept of gravity and certainly I have
a huge insight into the nature of the
world and that is my true Joy scientific
as a as a scientist my true joy as a
scientist that I want to encode in a
little number which is given as a reward
to the guy who is inventing the
experiments that lead to the data to the
data with the falling apples for example
right well and of course this is this
has been a challenge in machine learning
you know since the beginning which is
okay as we add more and more parameters
how do we prevent it from learning
spurious information with those
parameters and instead have it focus on
parsimonious explanations on regular
explanations on things that in this
Universe are more likely to generalize
you know to unseen examples and so I
think my question to you is does this
setup that you describe is it a form of
that and or what is the state of the art
you know these days for helping to push
or nudge neural networks towards
learning parsimonious models for the
world rather than highly detailed
spurious susceptible to you know high
frequency uh anomalies and adversarial
examples and all this sort of thing
yes what is the current state of the art
in regularizing
descriptors of the data such as neural
networks such that you get simple
explanations of the data such that you
get short programs that compute the data
in other words such that the description
of the data
is a short program that computes a much
larger raw data
and um and how close can we get to the
limits which are given through this
concept concept of algorithmic
information or call mcgarve complexity
tomograph complexity of any data is the
length of the shortest program on some
general computer that computes it since
in our field the general computers are
returned neural networks we want to find
a simple Recon Network that computes all
this data
and given one computation of the data we
want to find an even simpler one so we
want to ask this idea of compression
progress
and here I have to say although we have
lots of regularizers invented through
out the past few decades there's nothing
that is really convincing
I think one of the really important
missing things is um
to to make that work in a way that is
truly convincing that is as convincing
as chat GPT is today in the much more
limited domain of of generating text
from previously observed texts and stuff
a very old idea of um I think the 1980s
was to have weight decay in a neural
network which basically is the idea that
all the weights should um have um have
an incentive to become close to zero
such that you can prune them and so
people built in a regularizer that just
punished weights for being large or
being very negative
but that didn't work really well and
something better was flat minimum search
that was 1998 and first Arthur my
brilliant student back then roughly the
same time when the lstm paper came out
and uh and there
the idea is if you have um
if you plot
so weights of a neural network on on the
XX on the x-axis and you plot the error
on the y-axis and
um given the the weights you have high
or low error and then there is for
example a sharp error function which has
a sharp minimum which um which goes like
that can you see my finger so here here
is the x-axis here's the y-axis here's
the arrow and the error for a certain
weight is really really low but then for
a different weight in the environment in
the vicinity it's um hi again which
would be very different from a flat
minimum which would be like this and so
um here's the error and it's going down
and for many many ways it is low the
error and then it goes up again so if
you're a sharp very sharp well versus a
very broad well yes a sharp well versus
a broad well now if you are in a shop
well you have to specify the weights
with a lot with with high precision
so you have to spend many bits of
information on encoding the the weights
of this network as opposed to a large
um to a flat minimum where it doesn't
matter if you you know perturb the
weights um because the error remains uh
low in this flat minimum so what you
really want to find is is a network that
has low complexity in the sense that you
can describe the good Network source
with low error with very few bits of
information
and suddenly if you maximize or if you
minimize that flap minimum second order
error function then suddenly you have a
preference for Networks
that um
that
for example do this
you you have a hidden unit and the
outgoing weights they have certain
values but if you give a very negative
way to the hidden unit then it doesn't
matter what all these outgoing weights
do and flat minimum minimum search likes
to uh
find weight matrices like that where one
singing weight can eliminate many others
which you certainly don't need any
longer such as the description
complexity of the whole thing is much
lower than
in the beginning when you when you just
had a random initialization of all these
ways
so that is much more General than weight
Decay because weight Decay doesn't like
these strong ways it wants to remove
them but sometimes it's really good to
have a very negative weight coming to a
hidden unit which is Switched Off
through that weight such that all the
outgoing connections are meaningless
but it's not
um what you what you
it's very nice it's a very nice
principle but it's not as general as
finding the shortest program on a
universal computer that computes the
weight Matrix that is solving your
problem
how do you think we're going to get to
that point how do you think what
approaches are going to lead us to
finding things that approach comograph
complexity yeah and I think that part
has again a lot to do with meta learning
and as a system is able to run its own
learning algorithm on the network itself
it can suddenly speak about the
um
algorithms
in form of weight matrices and it can
discuss
Concepts such as the complexity of a
weight Matrix and then you can conduct a
search
in this space of
networks that generates
weight matrices and then you suddenly on
in the game so you are playing the right
game and then it's more a question of
how to
um
yeah
choose an initial learning algorithm
such as grain descent to come up with
something that computes The Simple
Solutions which you really want to see
in the end
sorry very recent papers on that on on
aspects of that um came out uh just um a
while ago with my students Vincent
Hermann and Luis quieres and um and uh
Francesco facho and my poster Kazuki
area and Robert Choi does also
um
and then the idea is really to have one
network that computes
an experiment
and the experiment itself is the weight
Matrix of a Recon Network
so
there is a generator of an experiment
which can be anything that
describes a computational interaction
with an environment
so a program so that experiment is then
executed in the real world
there's a prediction machine that
predicts the outcome of the experiment
before the algorithm is executed
and so then there is just a yes or no
question either
the following
outcome will occur or not either it will
occur or not
but now the entire setup is such that
you don't have predictions all the time
about every single Pixel no you just
have something which is very abstract
and which is just about whether a
certain unit of the Recon network is
going to be on or off at the end of the
experiment and this internal on and off
unit can represent any computational
question any questions that you can ask
at all and now the the task of the
experiment generator which is another
Network which generates a recurrent
Network weight Matrix which
represents the experiment the task of
this experiment generator is to again
come up with something that surprises
the um
the prediction machine which looks at
the experiment and says yeah it's going
to work or not and uh and suddenly you
are again in this old game except that
now you have
this world of abstractions where the
abstractions can be anything that is
computable
interesting really cool pretty cool
could we spend the last 10 minutes or so
just talking about some of the the
current AI landscape so in particular
the capabilities of gpt4
um the moat building thing and and the
the power that companies like uh Google
and open AI have and um also the
potential for open source so maybe we'll
just start with the you know the very
current capabilities of of gpt4 are you
impressed with it what do you think I'm
impressed in the sense that
um
I like the outcomes that you get there
and um it wasn't obvious a couple of
years ago that it would become so good
on the other hand of course it's not yet
this full AGI thing and it is not really
close to um
to justifying uh those fears that some
researchers sometimes now um
document and um in letters and public
letters and so on
so
to me it's a little bit
um
like a Visa view because
for for many decades I have had
discussions like that and people said
you are crazy when I said that within my
lifetime I want to build something that
is smarter than myself
and now suddenly in recent years
um some of the guys who said it's never
going to happen suddenly they just look
at chat gbt and they think oh now we are
really close to AGI and whatever
uh so um I I don't share these um
[Music]
extreme
um
I'm less impressed than some of those
guys let me say that
right the open source movement that you
mentioned you you want to ask a specific
question about that right
well yeah that was that famous Google
memo that got leaked and when the waits
for llama from Facebook went out within
about two or three weeks
um it was a valing pretty similar to
chat GPT you know with this um Laura
fine tuning and the open source
Community has just exploded you know you
can now run it on your laptop and there
is some question whether there is a
significant gap between the capability
you know is is it just a pilot trick is
it really as good potentially or could
it be as good as some of the next best
models from open AI but I guess the
question is do you think that we need
open AI to to have the best models
no of course not
um no I'm very convinced I'll see open
source movement and have supported that
some people say the open source movement
is maybe six or eight months behind the
large companies that are now um
coming out with these models and um
I think the the best way of making sure
that there won't be dominance through
some large company
is to support the open source movement
because how can a large company compete
against all these brilliant PhD students
around the world who are so motivated to
you know within a few days create
something that is a little bit better
than what the last guy has um put out
there on GitHub and whatever so I'm I'm
very convinced that this open source
movement is going to
make sure that there won't be
a huge mode for a long time
I'm reading between the lines here but I
would guess you would be opposed to
legislation like the EU is considering
where you know the very tight
restrictions on generative models you
know onerous onerous kind of uh approval
processes and things like that because
that's going to have this chilling
effect on on open source Innovation and
and the little guys wouldn't it
yes I have signed letters
um
which which support the open source
movement and whenever I get a chance to
um
maybe influence some EU
politicians then I'm trying to
contribute to making sure that they
don't don't shoot themselves in the foot
by
um by by killing killing Innovation
through the open source movement so you
certainly want to avoid that uh
lots of different open source movements
around the world so if one
big entity fails to support open source
or even makes it harder for open source
there will still be lots of other
entities which won't follow and so no
matter what's going to happen on the
political level I think
open source is not going away
I guess just in closing you've been in
this game for decades now and what is I
know it's a bit of a strange question to
ask but what's your fondest memory in
your career my fondest memory oh it's
usually when I discover something that I
think
nobody has seen before
but that is uh that happens very rarely
because most of the things you think of
somebody else has done before
but yeah yeah
um what usually happens is
um you and and this has happened many
times not many times but quite a few
times in my career since the 80s as a
scientist who publishes stuff
yeah
some of you think oh that is the
solution to all these problems and now I
really figured out a way of building
this Universal system which learns how
to improve itself and learns the way to
improve the way it improves itself and
so on and now we are done and now all is
that's necessary is to scale it up and
it's going to solve everything
and then you think a little bit long
about it and maybe you have a couple of
Publications but then it turns out
something is missing you know something
important is missing and yeah and
actually it's not that great and
actually you have to think her to add
something important to it which then for
a brief moment looks like see
greatest thing since sliced bread and
and then you get excited again but then
suddenly you realize oh
it's still not finished something
important is missing and so it goes back
and forth like that I think that's the
life of a scientist the greatest Choice
um those moments where you have an
Insight where suddenly Things fall into
place such that along the lines of what
we discussed before the description
length of some solution to a problem
suddenly it shrinks because two puzzle
pieces they suddenly match and uh and
become one or
become one in the sense that they fit
each other such as suddenly you have the
shared line between the two puzzle
pieces one is negative and the other one
is positive and certainly the whole
thing is um much more compressible than
uh there's some of the things separately
so um these these things that's what's
driving
um
scientists like myself I guess
wonderful um Professor you again Schmidt
it's been an absolute honor thank you so
much for coming on the show today thank
you it was such a pleasure talking to
you